[Music]
what are you doing who the hell are you
what are you doing here Celine how the
hell do you know her I'm afraid you've
come in a very anopportunity time
something dreadful has happened here I
can see that and I'm glad I got here
before it got any worse this is always
jump of the iceberg and it's a big
iceberg how can I put this delicately
Mort [ __ ] dude what dad like my hopes
and dreams and he's a flesh-eating
zombie do homo necrosis exactly hence
the gunman that is not hence the gun
waving those body guns around hold on
tell me what happened how did Mark die
it was murder and worse yet the body is
missing what show me and don't say that
word what word murder yes that worked
well I mean murder is a rather accurate
description of what do you not see the
lightening you saying it was lightening
that murdered mark well mother Nature
doesn't exactly strike me as having
murderous intent to count that time I
was sucked in new ball game tomorrow you
know look whatever's happening here is
tapping into forces far beyond our
control
[Music]
doc malarkey
Marco look marks death is a terrible
thing indeed but I fear that there are
forces much darker than anything we've
seen here today I'm well versed in the
arcane arts but if you untrained and
uninitiated can summon lightning with a
mere word we're all in far graver danger
than anything we can ever hope to face
alone we're gonna have to work together
if we're gonna survive this Selene what
are you proposing we need to speak with
Marc I knew it
he's a flesh-eating zombie no maybe one
of those smart zombies whom you said he
was on business no no I need to commune
with the dead that doesn't sound like a
good idea well it's a good thing I don't
need your permission but you you've been
awfully quiet through this whole thing
with those beady little eyes and wearing
those rags maybe I shouldn't have
trusted someone so goddamned gorgeous
I'll pass but I feel like I can trust
you my sense that you have a far greater
part to play in all of this will you
help me find an answer perfect
all right that's enough I'm not just
gonna sit around and let you drag my
partner off to there very likely death I
won't stand for it well I trust Selene
with all my heart I see no reason why an
any anyone should doubt her well I have
to agree with our intrepid detective
here just doesn't seem natural I never
liked this uptight [ __ ]
we walks around with a stick up his ass
but I think he's right something's weird
if it makes you feel any better you guys
can stand watch outside the door but my
work cannot be interrupted Oh believe
you me I'll be keeping a close eye on
every single one of you even myself
especially myself
sorry Celine wait wait yes are you all
right I know this news can't be settling
well with you I'm fine for now
but always talk vehicles mark is dead
wait I just didn't think it was the time
to become there's more to this world
that you could ever hope to imagine I
just had my eyes open to a small portion
of it just be careful you two
[Music]
thank you please have seat
now I'm sure this must be unsettling for
you being thrust into this series of
unfortunate events but I promise with
your help I'm going to get to the bottom
of this now I'm not sure who would want
to kill mark but something tells me this
seemingly significant event is actually
a footnote in a much larger mystery
unfolding in our midst
I've never been very comfortable in this
house but something tells me now that my
eyes are open there are dark forces
surrounding this Manor
[Music]
have it why did you stop did you see
something someone draw it what is this
this doesn't answer anything you need to
go back go back now what the [ __ ] is
this
get out we are not done here Selina I
think this is quite enough No come on
partner let's go come on hurry it up
what did she do to you what is this ba
ba what what is this mean anything to
you well maybe no sorry spit it out if
you got something well it could be our
groundskeeper George but he only works
on weekdays looks like your friend here
may disagree with that notion yeah you
the fifth chef if you know something for
God's sakes spit it up okay all right
all right
George has been living on the grounds
for years what and you just now thought
to share that information with us for
all we know he could be the murder
stop saying that word look George just
tells of the grounds man he's a [ __ ]
hermit I don't care what the [ __ ] he is
look all this arguing is getting us
nowhere just go outside and talk to this
George and be done with it you want to
say you're not coming with us I need to
stay here with Celine our friend is dead
I'm sorry I just need answers I already
lost one friend today
I don't want to lose another fine but I
need to stay here fine with me fine good
yeah whatever who cares all right you're
coming with me partner
you two hold on a sec we're missing
somebody who had eyes on the colonel
well he appeared tired and went back to
his room I'm sure he did and with any
luck he'll stay there
all right let's roll out come on lead
the way cookie cookie
I'm not your cookie I spent three weeks
at culinary school I earned the right to
be called chef I'm very impressed
just tell us where we're going come on
let's go
I think I see him
hey buddy hands where I can see him Hey
well the answer where they're supposed
to be unless of course you like to dig
the hole for yourself what the hell are
you doing here I'm the groundskeeper I
keep the ground all right I'd say look
around the ground is pretty well-kept in
its place right I'm sorry man this dick
made me bring him out here - shut up how
do you not know about the murders oops
how do you not hear that lightning
lightning is the skies business look at
the ground when the ground starts
shooting up lightning I'll let you know
all right that's smartass why exactly
are you digging that hole and why
shouldn't we suspect you for taking part
in the death of your employer employers
come and go some die some don't some are
murders someone not it's not my business
I'm digging this hole for a burst water
pipe if that's all right with your grace
on us see I told you George didn't do
nothing man see I just did nothing
forgive me for not taking you at face
value but we're all gonna come inside
we're gonna sit down and have a nice
lovely chat and get to the bottom of
this before I lose my mind and start
dabbling and murder myself now you
listen to me Sonny it's been 15 years
since I've been in that house and I'm
not about to break that winning streak
now I don't care how many murders
they've been I ain't going near that
house however there is one reason one
incident one manifestation that will get
me into that madhouse
[Music]
you and better pray to God that that
reason never comes to pass that there's
a reason
somebody help me
[Music]